ANITA KIBUNGUCHY: Finding
your data assets is one thing.
Managing both your technical
and business metadata while
maintaining proper
security requirements
is a whole other beast.
Luckily, Data Catalog can help.
Stay tuned as we cover how
to add schematized tags
to your data assets
as well as show you
how integration with
Cloud Identity and Access
Management or Cloud IAM provides
ACL controls on your metadata.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Data Catalog is a fully managed
and scalable data discovery
and metadata management service
that empowers organizations
to quickly discover,
understand, and manage
all their data in Google Cloud.
I am Anita Kibunguchy.
And today, we'll be tackling
how to understand your data
assets with schematized tags
in a safe and secure way.
Just like sticky notes,
Data Catalog tags
act as annotations.
Whereas other data catalogs
capture tags a simple text
strings, Data Catalog
captures business metadata
in a schematized
format via tags.
These tags can be created
through the UI as well
as custom APIs.
Users can now define a business
tag as string, double, Boolean,
or enumerated-- enum--
making it easy to catalog
and find data assets.
So you've heard us talk a lot
about technical and business
metadata.
So what do we mean
by these terms?
Technical metadata
is data that's
already saved in GCP services,
such as table names, column
descriptions, and date created.
This data is automatically
ingested from the data source
into Data Catalog without
any involvement on your part.
For example, if you add
a new table to BigQuery,
it will show up in Data
Catalog in a matter of seconds.
On the other hand,
business metadata
are tags that provide additional
business information that
is valuable to a customer.
This could include
PII, delete-by dates,
business logic,
data quality scores,
as well as governance tags.
By adding business
metadata, data assets
become more searchable
and usable for your team.
Let's take a look
at how you can add
rich information to your data
assets with tag templates.
On the Data Catalog home screen,
scroll to Tag Template section
and click on Create
a tag template.
Here, you can define
the template ID,
display name, as well
as add attributes
and define their type.
Each attribute type can be
string, double, Boolean,
or enum.
Once you've added
all your attributes,
click on Save Template.
Creating a tag template can
also be done programmatically
using custom APIs.
Let's learn more about
an existing tag template.
On the Data Catalog home screen,
scroll to the Tag Template
section and click on
Explore tag templates.
We'll look at the Data
Governance tag templates.
This template has tags to
help the data governance
team certify specific
data assets for use.
It also lets approved users know
which data assets they can use.
You'll notice that each
attribute has a type as well.
For data classification,
the type is enum.
From there, the
data governance team
can now define whether the data
asset is public, sensitive,
confidential, or
regulatory, and can then
apply the applicable
controls around it.
Now that you've explored
a tag template, let's look
at how the integration
with IAM helps with access
control of your data assets.
Instead of having to set
separate permissions or ACLs
to register data
assets, Data Catalog
auto-ingests tactical metadata
and honors existing source
ACLs.
This means that if a user
already has read access
to all data assets
in BigQuery, then
they'll be able to discover and
have read access to those data
assets in Data Catalog.
Similarly, this IAM integration
allows further access controls
to be set.
With Data Catalog, you
can set read access,
metadata read-only access, and
no read or no metadata read
access.
Depending on these
permission settings,
users' search results
and access can
be controlled, keeping highly
sensitive data limited to those
with the necessary access.
Thanks for watching, and please
check out all our Data Catalog
videos and visit our
website to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]